Demons in the White House is like the
saying that could just sum all this up
because we know that Satan is the puppet
master. The Bible says that Satan is the
god of this world and he has blinded the
minds of the masses. It says that we do
not wrestle against flesh and blood but
against principalities, against the
powers of the darkness of this age,
against this world. We are not messing
with physical people. These are puppets
for Satan that are running the White
House, that are running the world. And
if that sounds crazy to you, we're going
to get into it. We're going to prove
that so that you guys can see that for
yourself. This is from the New York
Times. Says, "Trump posted a picture of
himself as Jesus. Now, he's trying to
explain it away. The image showed
President Trump bathed in divine light
and clad in religious robes. His
interpretation was that the image
depicted him as a doctor, not Jesus
Christ. And I think that's pretty
interesting. I mean, if you look at this
picture, this was officially on Donald
Trump's social media. You can see it up
here. It has since been deleted because
of all the flack he's been getting. If
you replace that face with long hair and
a beard, people would automatically
assume that's Jesus just because of the
the attire.
He's placing his hand on a person in a
hospital bed and there's rays of light.
You can see in his hand there's rays of
light and there's even a woman praying
and people kind of looking up to him.
There's a military man looking up to
him. Uh, a lot of people are talking
about this thing in the background. It
looks like flying soldiers in the sky,
but this looks like a straightup demon.
There there is some fake news out there.
I fact checked it. They said this is
from a book and they gave a title and
they show the cover of the book. I
thought, well, the book looks like a AI
generated image. Anyway, I looked it up.
I can't find that any book exists. So,
if you see that post, don't share that
stuff. you know, we should be trying to
fact check everything before we share it
because we're mudding up the waters in
the truth community.
Um, you know, there's sometimes I'll
share something and I'll say, "Hey, I'm
not sure if it's true or not. Please
find it for me." Um, when I'm jumping on
something really early, but this this
was easy enough to search and see if
this book existed. So, here's the
picture. Donald Trump looking like Jesus
and all these memes are being made, all
these jokes like Trump wearing this
outfit and they're saying the doctors
are saying, "Sir, can we help you?"
Says, "No, I work here." So, they're
they're making fun of the fact that he
said that this that he looked like a
doctor. Um, you're starting to see these
like Halloween costumes come out that
say doctor, but you can tell obviously
it's Jesus robes and they're making a
joke about saying it was a doctor.
What I think is interesting [snorts] is
that it might not be Jesus. It might be
the magician from the tarot card. Uh you
can see the outfit looks identical. And
the reason I think that this really
could be it is because there is a lot of
illusions that Trump is a witch, that he
is a warlock, a magician. Even the word
maga, the word maga means witch in the
dictionary says in stories a woman who
is a who has magical powers.
And here this is on wisdom library. It's
Sanskrit dictionary and it says maga a
magician. A priest of the sun. A priest.
This is interesting. So not just a
magician but a priest of the sun. We
know in the last days there's going to
be a push towards a one world religion
that pushes people to towards sun
worship by force. And here you see a
priest of the sun is the word maga and
that happens to be his slogan.
At the bottom here it says a magician a
priest of the sun. Here you see that in
Italian, Latin and Polish the word maga
means sorceress, witch, magician.
So this is I mean we're starting to see
a connection between what he's wearing
and this tarot card that shows the
magician with a pentagram and a sword
and a chalice
uh getting ready to do some ritual. Now,
is it coincidence that Trump is the one
that started this war, right? That he's
initiating World War III, that there's a
rocket named Artemis, and Artemis
happens to be a goddess of sacrifice. I
think all these things go together. I
might be losing people with that, but I
don't believe that there are accidents
with these people. I think that so much
of this stuff is orchestrated. Um, you
see the numerology that they're into the
the names. Why is it called Artemis, a
goddess of sacrifice? Here he is wearing
this magician robes that happens to
match up
with the uh tarot card. And so it's
making me think of this verse right here
in Revelation 18:23. It says uh in the
highlighted section it says, "For thy
merchants were the great men of the
earth. For by thy sorceries were all
nations deceived. Now when you look up
that word sorcery in the Greek, you're
going to find that that has it's the
word pharmarmacia. It's where we get the
word pharmaceuticals from. So it's
interesting that he said I thought that
this was me as a doctor. What kind of
doctor? A sorcery.
See, we're talking about the
pharmarmacia. The pharmarmacia sorcery,
the magic, the magicians. These are the
people who are the merchants of the
world. Trump's one of the most
wealthiest men on this earth. And here
you see this image of him in the robes
of the magician.
I'm I'm starting to believe that there's
no coincidences in this thing. Now,
there's a magazine called The Economist,
and their covers often predict things
for that year. Every year they have a
cover with it's always like a collage.
And when you look at that collage, you
see things that are like predictive
programming. Like in this one, the the
world ahead for 2025. We talked about
this on another show, but when you look
in here, you see a vaccine. You see a
allseeing eye with nuclear bomb or
nuclear symbol. You see Saturn. There
was a lot of Saturn worship at Trump's
inauguration. His wife's hat was wearing
the Saturn hat. Uh there was a lot of
stuff. We have a whole video on that.
I'm not going to dig into all that
stuff. You guys need to check it out. Um
like a lot of these videos that we've
done the past year um is really talking
about this stuff. It's really
significant to what's going on right
now. And then the Economist 2026,
you see nuclear bombs. You see uh the
Aremis
rocket right here. You see um the 250th
anniversary of our country. There's a
two pennies here. I think that might
elude to the the penny being dissolved
away. Eliminating the penny. I can't say
that I know what all these things are. I
haven't really had time to look at all
the details. I just wanted to show you
that this magazine
is often really accurate with its cover.
And when you look at the cover for 2017,
what was it showing? It it says right
here, Planet Trump. Planet Trump. And
when you look at these tarot cards,
isn't that interesting? Tarot cards. You
will see it says the tower. You see
Christ on the cross back here and uh a
communist flag. You see judgment and
Trump is holding a staff and this holy
bomb. I don't remember what they call
it, but that's what the pope holds
often. U the world, you're seeing some
stuff here. You see all the different
media. You see the arts and
theater and books. And it's basically
showing you, I think,
the connection of the whole world. Uh
the hermit, I can't say I know what that
is, but this is the part I want you to
see.
Why was this on here? I mean, literally
right below the picture of Trump and it
says planet Trump and you see the
magician.
So, is it like coincidence that suddenly
now he's posting this image of him
wearing the attire of the magician? He's
placing his hand on a dying man wearing
these robes of the magician. The
sorcerers are those who rule the world.
Pharmarmacia sorcery. Marina Abramovic.
She's this Satan worshshiping witch of a
woman and she says some interesting
things in these interviews. I want to
show you this is a one minute clip.
Listen carefully.
>> You know I'm sure to share with you one
really funny opinion but there is a in
Lapland there is a group of the in the
shamans there who do something called
collective dreaming. She said shamans.
There's a group of shamans that do
something called collective dreaming.
Okay, listen to this.
>> They will go together in seclusion and
do the rituals with you know eating very
little food and being in a in in
solitude for a long time and they will
go and dream the dreams and the dream
have to be called it the same dream. So
coming out of this dream this once of
the shaman told me that actually the
best thing happened this in this planet
right now is the Trump to be the
president. I say how is this possible is
the best thing to happen. He say yes
because because he's so irrational he's
so crazy that's actually create that
wakening that we finally wake up because
before it will be another guy and
another guy and everything looks similar
but he's so different than anything
else. So they actually he's the the
magician who waking us up. What do you
think about that?
>> That's kind of the
>> Is this all just coincidental or is it
prophetic? She said that these shamans
had a collective dream that
Trump becoming president is the best
thing that can ever happen because he's
so chaotic that it will wake us up.
I mean, that's crazy to me because these
people operate out of order, out of
chaos. Now, she's saying that he's a
magician, that he operates out of chaos,
and that it'll cause people to wake up.
Meaning, I believe that we're we're
going to wake up and say, "We need
change. Something's got to happen in
this world, and we will run to new world
order." We'll say, "We need some kind of
order because this place has been chaos
forever." And guess what? Satan's got a
plan. He's got his puppets to come out
and bring in the new world order. It's
going to look like peace and safety.
It's going to look so good. Believe me,
when you see the Pope come out and say,
"All I want is peace." That's what's
happening right now. All of MAGA is
turning their back on Trump and people
are defending the Pope, even the
liberals. We're going to get into this.
I got more to show you guys.
Here's another clip from the same
satanic lady. Listen what she said. But
look at these two guys, Trump with Kim
Jong
>> Kim Jong.
>> They're two lunatics, completely
horrible human beings, corrupted and and
and
you know, we don't we don't like them
because there lots of good reasons not
to like them. I just talked to the last
I was in Rome two days ago and I met one
shaman woman from the north of um
Norway. So this woman told me three days
ago that the Trump is the best thing
happened ever to us
because she believed not her but the
entire you know population of this
Nordic magician
>> that he is the magician of the highest
order that he is there in his irrational
mind to create confusion in order that
the human being can find new order and
you know it's not so stupid
thinking about this in that way. He's
completely turning things.
>> You heard that, right? To find order.
He's the magician of the highest order.
He's going to bring about order. Listen
to this.
>> Upside down.
>> Uhhuh. I'm going to back it up.
>> Because to create confusion in order
that the human being can find new order.
And you know, it's not so stupid
thinking about this in that way. It's
completely turning things upside down.
>> Uhhuh. Because since Trump is around,
things are changing.
Because we are waking up.
>> Remember, he's a magician of the highest
order, MAGA,
to to bring about chaos, to wake us up,
to bring about order. It's insane. This
is how these people operate. And they're
telling us right to our faces. This
stuff is right out in the open in
interviews. And this is blowing my mind.
So, all this stuff is coming to pass.
And you know what? God really opened my
eyes to something because I I kind of
thought that things were going to go a
certain way. I thought Trump was going
to be the one to really bring our
country back to God and it was going to
be this false Christianity that he was
going to bring back with Christian
nationalism and everybody's going to
embrace it because, you know, everything
was so woke and chaotic and he's going
to bring in he's gonna get rid of the
woke and everybody's like cheering on.
And that really happened, but I thought
that it was going to keep going that
direction and he was gonna embrace with
the pope and it was going to be, you
know, because the Bible talks about in
Revelation, it talks about how America
and Rome are going to unite together and
they're going to form this one world
religion. So, I really thought that that
was how this was going to go. But then
one one day, a year ago, like an instant
download, I I believe the Holy Spirit
impressed me that Trump was going to be
set up as a false Antichrist. And I'm
going to show you that clip. I'm going
to show you where I started talking
about this a year ago. And now I'm
seeing it happening. It's blowing my
mind right now because um Donald Trump
actually started going off on all his
people like his MAGA crew. Candace
Owens, Alex Jones, Tucker Carlson, uh
Megan Kelly, and he just started
blasting on him. And now they're turning
on him because they're saying, "Why are
you even in this war?" Like, why can't
we just have peace? And so you see
Candace Owens, man, she used to be all
about some Trump. Now listen to the what
she's saying now.
>> Trump is very clearly under demonic
influence. I think Paula White probably
put a spell on him of some sort. I mean,
he is surrounded by ironically the very
thing that he accuses me and Megan and
Tucker of being because we're calling
for peace.
>> Isn't that crazy? So, she just said that
she thinks he's under a demonic
influence. And then here's Tucker
Carlson. You know, these guys are buds
and
Candace Owens has nearly six million
subscribers. So, she has a very loud
voice in the community. And Tucker
Carlson has 5 12 million subscribers.
And listen to what he just said.
>> This isn't so much a couple of memes.
These are
these are icons iconography. These are
attempts to send a statement about
faith. What statement is the president
sending? Well, not a coherent one.
Doesn't actually add up to a theology.
It's mockery. He's mocking Jesus. He's
making fun of Christianity. The central
figure of the religion is being held up
for mockery, of course. And his
description of how this got out is
itself mockery. Mockery of the idea of
truth. One day he says, "Yeah, I did
it." Next day he says, "No, I didn't do
it." Both are on video. That's not
really a lie. It's more than a lie. It's
bigger than a lie. It's an attack not
just on a specific set of facts. It's an
attack on the idea that there are facts.
It's an attack on truth openly.
No one's hiding this.
>> In the background of Tucker Carlson, you
can see a poster that says Fatima. I've
I've always been curious, why does he
have this poster that says Fatima?
Because Fatima was an event or a place
or something. It was a a a historical
event that happened in the Catholic
faith where three children, shepherd
children, saw an apparition of Mary and
thousands of people saw this as well.
And there was like miracles that
happened. People were healed. Uh the
rain stopped supernaturally, the sun
danced around, all kinds of stuff. And
I'm like, why does he have this word
Fatima in the background? And I feel
like it's like this subliminal product
placement for the Catholic Church. And I
don't think that Tucker Carlson claims
to be a Catholic. In fact, he wears the
red thread on his wrist of Cabala. So, I
don't know where this guy stands. I
don't trust any of these people. But
what I'm saying is that these are the
loudest voices in our world today. So,
when they say something, people listen
and they're starting to say Trump's
demonically possessed. Trump's the
antichrist. He's blasphemous. We need to
turn against him. And so I I started
asking uh Google like how many people
are saying that Trump is the antichrist.
And Marjorie Taylor Green, who worked
for Trump, says the former congresswoman
reported reportedly stated in April 20
26 this month, that Trump's posting of
an AI image showing him as Jesus like
was more than blasphemy and constituted
as an antichrist spirit. Clint Russell,
I don't even know who that is, host of
right-wing Liberty Lockdown podcast, who
stated in April 2026, this month again,
that he had gone from hesitantly voting
for Trump to thinking there is a decent
chance he's the antichrist.
Marina Perus, a British television pu
pundant pundit
who publicly described the president as
the antichrist after he posted an AI
image of himself as Jesus.
Red D, you get the point. Even Jack
White from the White Stripes frontman
compared Trump to the Antichrist in an
Instagram post following the same AI
image controversy in April 2026. I mean,
as far as I know, Jack White is doesn't
claim at all to be a Christian. And yet,
he saw this post and thought, "This guy
could be the Antichrist." Pretty
interesting that this keeps popping up.
Now, this is the type of stuff we're
starting to see in the news is this
whole Trump versus Pope thing. It says
President erupts at Pope and draws a
backlash. Analysis: How Trump versus
Pope Leo could impact elections.
Where's the Pope? How's the Pope getting
sucked into this? This was a a post by
Trump that everybody's starting to say
it's it's distasteful. It's blasphemous.
You're the Antichrist. How How the Pope
get sucked into this? We're talking
about somebody in the Vatican, Rome.
What does he got to do with America? A
lot. When you look into Bible prophecy,
I want you guys to watch the videos that
we have in the past. Scroll back through
our old stuff and watch videos like the
the mark of the beast is not a chip. You
will find out who the antichrist is. The
woman that sits on the scarlet harlot
that sits on the beast with seven heads.
The Bible says that the seven heads or
seven mountains or seven hills. And when
you look up, just Google what is the
city of seven hills? Boom. It'll tell
you Rome. And then you find out that a a
woman represents a church, but this is a
harlot. So this is a corrupt church
sitting on the city of Rome, which would
make it the Vatican. Right? There's so
many things that point to Vatican papacy
being the antichrist system. And we go
we go through all that stuff in that
video.
But there's going to be a connection
with America, the second beast, uniting
or pointing all people to worship the
first beast, Rome. There's going to be a
connection where they form a one world
religion that's enforced by law. And it
says right here, Pope Leo for president.
Meeting with Obama guru sparks
speculation.
Uh, now they're starting to talk about,
look, Pope Leo's secret meeting fuels
presidential speculation.
Eligibility would depend. Like there's
actually starting to be some talk of the
pope of Rome being our president. And he
just happens to be the first American
pope ever. So, I I've known since 2012
that America and Rome were going to
unite. But when I saw that we had an
American pope, I was like, I this was a
turn I didn't expect. And now they're
talking about him being the president
and that our current president is the
antichrist. This is all very important.
And I'm going to show you the video from
a year ago because God helped me see
that this is going to be how this works.
That Satan is playing both sides. He is
the puppet master. All these people are
pawns in the game and he's setting up
the stage right now for Satan to appear
as Christ. And how can Satan appear as
Christ? He has to overthrow a fake
Antichrist. We're going to go into that.
Trump attacks Pope Leo as too liberal
and weak on crime. So that's what this
that's how the Pope got dragged into
this. Trump started attacking him
because the Pope was saying, "Hey, we
want peace. Why can't we just have
peace?" And Trump's like, you know, he
doesn't know what he's talking about.
He's too weak and liberal. And so here's
USA Today saying, "Pope Leo for
president meeting with Obama Guru sparks
speculation."
This video was streamed in February 26,
2025. It's only 20 minutes. I'm going to
run this as the ending of this thing
because
over a year ago, God opened up my eyes
to something that I didn't see before.
It happened in a moment on a live
stream. We were talking about Trump, but
we were talking about how Trump was
going to work with the Pope and how all
this stuff was going to go down. And in
a moment, it was like, wait a minute,
what if Trump is actually going to be
set up as some kind of decoy antichrist
and this is going to go totally
different than we expected? And now over
a year later, we're starting to see the
fulfillment of this that all those who
voted for him are starting to say, "Wait
a minute. I think we just voted for the
Antichrist.
All right, guys. You I want you to just
check this out. What is up everybody?
Thank you for joining us at Candid
Truth. We're going to talk about the
truth and we're going to get candid with
it. There was a lot of Christian people,
right-wing people that thought Trump,
he's the Messiah. He's going to come.
He's going to change the world. He's
going to make America great again. And I
think they're in a I think they're in
for a wakeup call. When you look at what
Trump just posted today, people are
starting to ask questions. This is
Trump's official
Instagram. And if you haven't watched
this video, prepare to be shocked. This
is live. I'm not censoring the comment
section that's on Instagram, but we're
going to look at the comment section
because it's pretty crazy that even
Trump fans are saying, "I should have
voted for Kamla." Like people are
starting to have a change of heart about
Trump and it's only February. So what is
up with all the golden Idol stuff of
Trump? There's a video if you haven't
checked it out on Candid Truth. Check it
out. It says the deception is greater
than we thought and it has Trump on
there. It shows the golden calf. It
shows all his fans with the patch on
their ear showing that they are
idolizing this guy. They're just being
deceived. Trump is a pawn. He is another
puppet in the whole game. And I want to
show you um just some of these comments
in the comments section. I'll try to
expand on these, but it says, "This has
to be the most dis disrespectful and
tonedeaf thing a president could do.
111,000 likes on it." Now, remember,
everybody right now is kind of liking
Trump. Even the people that used to not
like Trump are now liking Trump. So,
this isn't just like the haters when he
was in the first term. This says, "This
video is truly horrifying. They are
dancing and celebrating over the bodies
of innocent children."
This is crazy. Uh, as a Trump supporter,
horrible post. Trump supporters are now
saying like, "We regret voting for you."
Look, okay, maybe I should have voted
for Kamla. Somebody says, "I'm a Trump
supporter and what the is this crazy?
This is the worst thing I've seen on the
internet all year. Trump, I voted for
you. For you to have a better economy,
better laws, and take care of our
country. Stay focused on the future and
our nation. I don't create obstacles,
blah blah blah. Obviously, he does not
like this either. WTF is this. Somebody
says, "How does a sitting president post
something like this?" And there,
everybody's just going off on this. And
notice it says right here, "Comments on
this post have been limited." I don't
know if that's set by Trump, set by
Instagram, or what, but um things are
starting to get a little weird. So, I
have a hypothesis. This is something
that I said a week ago and again last
night before this video came out. I want
to show you my hypothesis because I
believe that Satan is so cunning and
crafty and deceptive that we're we're
all like being misdirected by the
magician, by the sorcerers.
And these people, this is the Hegelian
dialect. They play both sides. They're
playing left and right. They're playing
red and blue. They're playing
Republican, Democrat. Satan is playing
good cop, bad cop. And while he's
getting your attention over here, he's
doing something else over here. It's
slight of hand. So, I'm going to play a
clip from um a week ago on our stream,
and I want you to hear what I say here.
We know Satan plays both sides.
What if all this is purposeful to make
Trump look like the Antichrist?
Literally because if like you're saying
dispensationalists, they're looking for
who is the one that was wounded and had
a deadly wound and was healed. You know,
Trump supposedly got shot. Uh he's on
the coin of Israel. He's going to make a
covenant. He's talking about peace and
safety. What if all lives go to Trump?
He is him. He's the Antichrist. He fits
everything.
Then the true Antichrist comes, which is
Satan.
>> Satan is gonna appear. What what we're
waiting for before Christ returns is
Satan to manifest in our world as a
cosmic savior, a supernatural being,
more deceptive than Trump ever could be,
more deceptive than the Pope ever could
be, more deceptive than any human being
could ever be. Because you now you're
talking about an angel of light
>> who's doing signs and wonders and
miracles and healing the world and
getting rid of pandemics and stopping uh
natural disasters, quote unquote natural
disasters and wars and all these things.
What if he comes and kills Trump, the
Antichrist,
and everybody's like, "This is Jesus,
this supernatural being that literally
killed the oneman Antichrist that we've
been looking for.
So this is this is crazy because the way
I understand prophecy I do not believe
that we are looking for a one-man
antichrist. I don't believe that all
these left behind movies, all the
mainstream uh Christianity after the um
the counterreformation or after the
reformation, the counterreformation came
and they were trying to misdirect people
from seeing that the Roman Catholic
Church, the papacy, the the Roman Empire
is the antichrist system. When you see
the word antichrist in the Bible, it's
always plural. It says there are many
antichrist. Even now the antichrist
spirit, it's never pointing out to a
one-man ruler. And I believe it's its
positions. People are are disposable.
Even if Pope Francis is in the seat now,
in a year he could not be in the seat.
So you can't point at Pope Francis and
say he's the antichrist because someone
can take his place. But whoever is in
the position, whoever's sitting in that
seat saying I am Christ on earth, I am
God on when it wears that crown that
says vicarious fail day, which means the
substitute of Christ on earth. They are
antichrist and the whole system is
antichrist.
But I believe that there's a tons of
propaganda out there. This uh
counterreformation
propaganda that says, "No, we're looking
for a one man in the future, some
political leader that's charismatic and
does all these things." Well, first I
want to show you this clip where I said
this last night on Brad's stream on
Strange Normal. I think Satan is got
this whole thing, man. It's a puppet
show. He plays both sides. the Hegelian
dialect.
He is it's it's a slight of hand. It's
misdirection.
Because what I think is everybody's
gonna at first think Trump's awesome.
Like, man, things are changing. Things
are great. Actually, things are going
better. Gas is better. Uh he's getting
rid of all the woke stuff and all this
stuff. But then they're going to start
recognizing, wait a minute, he he's
handinand with Elon, who wants to
microchip our brains. He is. Okay, so
you get the point. Now, check this out.
So, I just asked Chat GBT what is
basically the mainstream idea of who the
what the markers are for the Antichrist.
Check this out. It says he will rise
from a revived Roman Empire. That's in
Daniel 9:26 or 90 27. Now, I don't agree
with everything this is going to say.
I'm just telling you what the majority
of the Christian world believes. That's
the whole point. That's why it's so
important to understand prophecy to know
that we're going to be here during the
tribulation. We're not going to be
raptured out of here. That um all kinds
of stuff that the that the Antichrist is
not one man but a system. And that Satan
is going to come on the scenes as
Christ, as a cosmic Christ. He's going
to be doing lying signs and wonders,
miracle working demons. He's going to
have supernatural power to bring down
fire from heaven and all these things.
How are we going to be able to resist
something that powerful? We've never
been faced with a supernatural being who
is basically like a superhero and can do
everything from healings. If you don't
believe Satan can heal, go talk to a
newager who's doing Reiki and crystal
healing, all this stuff. Satan has crazy
amount of power that he can do lying
signs and wonders. He can put an ailment
on somebody, remove that ailment, and
now they've been healed. quote unquote
healed, right? So, this is going to be a
being that is supernatural and is going
to end the antichrist reign. But this is
what I think. This is what I believe.
Satan is in control of everything. This
is his world. He's the god of this
world. He's working through the the
governments of this system. It says we
we battle not against flesh and blood
but against principalities against the
powers and the ruler the rulers of the
darkness of this age of this world. So
he's putting all the people in place
preparing them to do to bring about one
world religion, one world government,
the new world order.
So Trump is just a pawn. He's a player
in the game. Now, all the Christians are
looking for a one-man Antichrist before
Christ returns. So, Satan cannot come if
he's going to really deceive the world,
he can't just come as Christ right now
because he would be he would be going
ahead of the game, right? Christians are
all looking for an antichrist. So, Satan
can't step out on the scenes as Christ
yet because we're still looking for an
antichrist. get it?
If he came out on the scene right now as
Christ, we would all say, "Wait a
minute. This isn't Christ. This is the
Antichrist." Because the Antichrist has
to come first. So, Satan is going to set
up a fake Antichrist.
You hear this? And and while all and
it's going to be obvious, it's going to
match all the markers that people are
looking for in the the understanding
they have of prophecy. So, it says right
here that he'll confirm a 7-year
covenant with Israel. Well, I think
that's very interesting because it says
Israel group mints Trump coin to honor
Jerusalem.
Trump is on a coin for Jerusalem for
Israel and and his face is right there
by King Cyrus. Why is an American
president on a coin for Israel? So,
here's marker number one. People are
going to be like, "Wait a minute." See,
everybody's going to Everybody's going
to embrace him at first. They're going
to embrace Trump and say, "Look, he's
getting rid of everything. This is
great." But then they're going to say,
"Wait a minute. We we've been deceived
by the Antichrist.
Wait a minute. He's matching all the
markers." It says he will break the
covenant at midpoint. So, we haven't got
there yet. Um, he will be a charismatic
political leader promising peace.
Okay. Has Trump is Trump a charismatic
leader? Yeah. Is he, you know, his fans
are idolizing him. Put a put a patch on
your ear and all this stuff, right? He's
charismatic and he's making these funny
tweets and all that kind of stuff. Now,
what did Trump say? We have before us a
rare opportunity
to bring security and stability and
peace to this region and to its people.
>> Okay. Security and peace is what he
said, right? And what does the Bible
say? 1 Thessalonians 5:3. For when they
shall say peace and safety, then sudden
destruction cometh upon them as travail
upon a woman with child, and they shall
not escape. So Trump is openly
fulfilling these prophecies
that all Christians are looking for in
the Antichrist that we know is supposed
to come before the true Christ. And so
Satan, who's going to appear as a
supernatural being and wants to deceive
the world into thinking that he's
Christ, has to set up a fake false
Antichrist decoy first. And it's all
lining up. He will suffer a fatal head
wound and be revived. Okay, maybe I'm
grasping here, reaching at straws, but
and I don't even believe this. So, I'm
not even falling for this ketchup pack
on the ear. That was literally not even
a scab a week later when he's on TV.
He's like, "Oh yeah, I'm a fast healer.
Real fast healer." Dude, I have zits
that last longer than this guy's assault
rifle ear wound. But either way, he's
been uh an attempted assassination on
him more than once, twice within a
year's time. And uh that's when they
really idolized him like a messiah.
Like, yeah, God's protecting him. Look,
he survived the assassination attempt.
So maybe I'm reaching with this whole
deadly wound that he's, you know, he
revives from a fatal wound, but even
that is close.
Then it says he will claim to be God and
demand worship.
He'll claim to be God. All right. What
do we see here?
Literally the golden idol. Like the
video I did a month or two ago, whenever
it was, when it says the deception is
greater than we thought, and it shows
Trump with a golden calf and everybody
idolizing him with the the patch on
their ear. I had no clue that he was
going to release a video showing him as
a golden image.
Remember, there's going to be an image
to the beast. All people must bow before
the image of the beast, just like
Nebuchadnezzar, right? And and then here
it shows that in shops he's going to
have little idols be sold. Dude, this is
crazy. If anyone if anyone is fitting
the the markers of what mainstream
Christians believe about the Antichrist,
it's Trump. He's even at the last trump.
People have put that together, too, like
that Christ is going to return at the
last trump. Christianity doesn't have a
a proper understanding of who the beast
is. They think the beast is a person, a
one-man person. And they've always been
looking for him as an American
president. Is it is it Obama? His name
means lightning from heaven and all this
stuff. They've been looking for this.
They've been Christians attention is
looking for a oneman antichrist. And
they're looking for all these markers
and Trump just happens to be fulfilling
these markers.
Um, it says he will have a global
government and economic control.
Oh, okay. He's gonna have a global
government and economic control. Look at
this. What does this say?
It's Trump's world. European leaders
divided on how to navigate this
coacapony. I don't even know how to say
that. Kacaphony. [snorts] It's Trump's
world. This is just one article. Trump.
Why does an American President Trump
travel all around the world giving
speeches?
Jerusalem has his face on their coin.
Trump Gaza, he's going to turn Gaza into
this like tourist attraction. He will be
empowered by Satan and he will persecute
Christians and Jews. He will be
empowered by Satan. Who's his right-hand
man?
Trump's right-hand man is Elon Musk, who
wants to microchip your brain. And and
what are all Christians looking for?
They're looking for a mark that you take
in your hand or in your forehead. And
they think it's a microchip. I don't
believe that. I believe that the mark of
the beast, Revelation is all is all
symbolic. Every prophecy that God gave
to man, it was symbolic. Joseph had a
dream about stars bowing down to stars
and stalks of wheat bowing down to
wheat. And Nebuchadnezzar had a dream
about an image and it was about
kingdoms. Daniel had a dream about
beasts rising out of the sea and it was
about kingdoms. Uh Peter had a vision
about a sheep being let down with
unclean animals and it had nothing to do
with eating unclean animals. Peter even
said, "I don't even know what this
means, Lord. I haven't eaten anything
unclean. What does this mean?" And when
you keep reading, people don't like to
know this truth, but when you keep
reading, the whole vision was about do
not call any gentile unclean. It was all
about stop judging the Gentiles. They're
grafted in. So, and and when you look at
Revelation, there's not really going to
be a woman, a harlot, riding on a
seven-headed beast, drinking blood.
That's not It's symbolic. A woman
standing on the moon clothed with the
sun. This is all symbolic. So, Israel is
symbolic. We are Israel. There's neither
Jew nor Greek. We're all one in Christ
Jesus. So when you see Israel in in the
book of Revelation, it's talking about
believers. When you see Babylon in the
in Revelation, Babylon doesn't even
exist anymore. But it's a symbol or a
sign of the wicked.
God's people are going to have a seal in
their foreheads. Do you think that's a
literal seal? No. I don't I don't know
any Christian that believes that we're
going to be literally having a seal on
our forehead. But for some reason, they
say that the the mark of the beast, oh,
that's definitely physical. Definitely
literal and physical. But it's not. It's
all about worship. He's going to cause
the world to worship the beast in his
beliefs, in his mind, or in the works of
his hand. You can take the mark of the
beast in your mind or in your hand. If
you if you believe the system, you took
it in your mind. You believe it. If you
don't believe it, but you're going to do
it anyway, like bowing to the image
instead of saying, "Throw me in the
fiery furnace." If you simply bow your
body, you bow to the beast, but you
don't believe in it. You're taking it in
the hand, the works of the hand. You can
receive the mark of the beast two ways.
You can only receive the mark of the of
God, the sign of God in your mind
because it's all about belief. His
right-hand man is the dude that wants to
microchip your brain. And Trump is
unrolling Stargate.
Stargate is a a worldwide surveillance
system
that's 24-hour surveillance by AI
technology. No human has to watch
anymore. And the guy who started this,
who owns Oracle, a company Oracle, Larry
Ellison, said people will behave,
they'll be on their best behavior when
they're being monitored 247 by AI.
This is the dystopian world that we are
about to enter. Actually, uh Trump calls
it the golden age. And if you look into
what the golden age is, this is what all
the occultists, all the esoteric writers
like Alice Bailey and um some of those
other people said is the age of
Aquarius. This is what the new age
movement has been looking forward to and
they predicted that it would be in 2025.
Alice Bailey said that in 2025 there
would be the externalization of the
hierarchy, meaning there would be an an
external manifestation of fallen angels,
demons among our world. And what are we
seeing today? Quote unquote drones
everywhere. We're seeing the military
say that we communicate with non-human
intelligences.
First they said we we see UFOs every
day. Then they said we're communicating
with them. Now they're picking up crafts
that look like eggs. And we're going to
do a show on what does that mean? What
what symbolically is where is all this
going? Um, according to the esoteric
writings with the egg and people talking
to these divine feminine beings, this is
all part of the big plan. Satan's final
deception. I don't know where you guys
stand on this issue. I hope this is eye
opening for you. But I truly believe
that Satan right now is setting up the
false antichrist and it's Trump. And
right now he's fitting all the markers.
And because of this video, this is the
start of people who even voted for him
saying, "I
wish [clears throat] I would have never
voted for you." And I'm starting to see
something in you that I don't like. And
people are starting to put the pieces
together. And I think more and more
people are going to start calling him
out as the antichrist. And when he's
identified as the antichrist, the stage
is being set for Satan to appear as the
cosmic Christ, a supernatural being
who's going to put an end to what Trump
is doing. Whether that's to put an end
to Trump or his system or whatever, but
then he's going to unroll this false
system of peace and safety and a
revival. what looks like a true revival,
but it's really a coexist
uh one world religion. And if you stand
on truth, thus sayeth the Lord, the Ten
Commandments, if you do not budge from
what God says in his ten commandments,
you will be public enemy. Number one,
you will be locked away. You will be
persecuted and finally you will be
beheaded because you are a discordant
note in this perfect utopia of a coexist
one world religion. and you're just some
extremist zealot that needs to be put
away because you're causing
chaos in our perfect world. That's
what's soon to come. Thank you guys for
tuning in. I hope this was eyeopening.
You know, I'm starting to see that
people are going towards Pope Leo, like
even liberal people because Pope Leo is
a LGBTQ advocate. He's standing up for
peace and all these things. But remember
what the Bible says when he says peace
and safety, sudden destruction will come
upon them. And that's what we're going
to see. But we know that all the world
is going to wander after the beast,
wonder after the beast, that John was
fixated on the harlot, the Vatican, and
all the world is going to wonder after
her. This is soon to happen. I see it
happening right now with this whole Pope
Leo thing. the first American pope.
Prophecy is coming true. If you guys
believe it, please give this video a
thumbs up. It really helps this video
get out into the algorithm. We love you.
We thank you. We cannot do this without
you. If you'd like to support this
ministry, you can do so by going to
candidruth.org. We got cash app,
zel, PayPal, and Patreon. If you like
cool merch, we got t-shirts, hoodies,
mugs, all kinds of stuff. We get about
$5 per sale on this. It really helps to
keep this ministry going. And if you
have been giving to this ministry, we
see you. We love you. We try to contact
you guys every time you send a donation.
Some some apps like Zel and Cash App
won't let us really give a message, but
we want to tell you thank you. We love
you. We cannot do this without you. And
we'll see you next time on Can of Truth.